le département de la réunion aux côtés
des réunionnais le pass transport a été
mis en place pour faciliter le
déplacement des personnes handicapées
dans leur vie quotidienne et pour
favoriser leur autonomie course docteur
loisirs ce dispositif est une compétence
facultative du département il s'agit
d'une aide individuelle versée sous
forme de chèque d'un montant de 300
euros par an elle est accordée pour une
durée de un an
à qui s'adresse-t-il il est destiné aux
adultes handicapés justifiant une
reconnaissance de leur handicap dans la
commission des droits et de l'autonomie
pour les personnes handicapées et ne
nécessitant pas de véhicule adapté pour
se déplacer comment
vous pouvez contacter la direction
autonomie service mobilité inclusion au
02 62 90 37 90 ou par mail passe @ cg974
point fr ou avoir plus d'informations
sur www.damart.fr 4 point fr rubrique
sociale pass transport
[Musique]